اللا شك هو هو كثير حتى من المصادر
المحليه لدينا مثلا كتاب درر نحور حور
العين كان لدينا صوره ايضا قديمه المخطوطه
وايضا يشير الى احداثها في المنطقه
للسعوديين قبل تحقيق هذا الكتاب وقيس على
ذلك الحقيقه ايضا غير هذا الكتاب نجد
السفارات المختلفه الدوله السعوديه وايضا
لقياداتهم ايضا في العراق وايضا في الشام
فهناك ايضا علاقات اجتماعيه وعلاقات
سياسيه وايضا علاقات تبادل مصالح الان
فيما بينها ولهذا نجد بين الفنيه والاخرى
ظهور ايضا هذه الكتابات التاريخيه بخلاف
الوثائق التي تقدم صوره النمطيه جديده
ربما غير يعني غير موجوده
هل اكتشفت اشياء جديده مثلا في المصادر
غير المحليه يعني مثلا زي هذه مصادر مؤرخي
اليمن مؤرخي العراق سوريا مصر الى اخره او
من خلال الوثائق الاسر او من خلال يعني هل
مازلنا موعودين بمفاجات جديده انا اعتقد
البحث العلمي يعني الحافل بك المزيد
والجديد من وثائق تاريخ بلادنا ولهذا كان
عرضنا في سابقا يعني نتمنى ايضا في هذا
المكان او هذا الموقف يعني
الايجاد المشروع الضخم للمتحف او الارشيف
الوطني للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وان يكون
في الدرعيه يعني هذا امل حقيقه كل الباحث
وكل مهتم لان الوثائق هؤلاء التي تتناقل
لدي الباحثين ولدي المهتمين لابد انها
تكون في مكان واحد يطلع الكثير من الناس
على جزء ايضا من تاريخ بلادهم واثارهم
الان في هذه المنطقه